you're born with intuition you're born
with knowing exactly what you want and
how you feel you're so connected to
yourself as a baby and then you kind of
lose it based on the mirror that you
have and you know other factors society
and things like that but when that
mirror isn't the healthiest and when no
one's really inquisitive and kind of
honoring you and teaching you boundaries
in a healthy way right you're not stolen
you but teaching you how to self-soothe
you know how to validate yourself those
are two huge huge huge parts of
emotional health that we oftentimes
don't get and explain those just a
little bit more self-soothed and then
the other one
pursue and validate yourself what does
that even look like so validation is
that you honor what you think and how
you feel regardless of it so regardless
of how anyone else feels or what anyone
else says your validation is how do I
how do I feel about this how do I feel
about this what do I think and what do I
need right now and and validating that
that thought because essentially that
thought's coming from your inner child
right so if I honor that then she feels
seen and heard and validated right if I
don't then I'm judging her and then I
shame her right so how many times have
we said I don't know why I feel the way
I feel like I don't want to feel this
way like it's ridiculous for me to feel
this way I should be over it by now or
something like that right denying
denying denying yeah exactly not
listening to her not validating her
you're judging her you're shaming her
um and when that happens you start to
build this um first of all divide
between you and that inner self right
and there's no trust there so now she
starts to shut up so when she does feel
something and this is called suppression
she just doesn't say anything she just
keeps it down keeps it down the ability
to self-soothe is different for everyone
and so you kind of have to find you know
like what works for you you're not going
to sit there you know on a first date
and be like oh my God I love myself okay
just be a little anxious right now don't
worry about himself soothing so you kind
of have to figure out and you really get
to know yourself in this process of like
hey like what can I do that would make
you feel better you know and having
those kind of like internal
conversations you really get to learn
about yourself and like who you are and
what makes you feel good and honoring
that and it's kind of you know I tell
people all the time whether they have
children or not you are essentially
learning how to babysit yourself or to
parent yourself so if I said hey we're
going to end this and you're going to
have a seven-year-old with you for the
next three months or a five-year-old or
a two-year-old or a 14 year old and now
you have to parent based on where that
child's at and look at all the things
that you just naturally will give her
that you just don't give yourself and
and it's it's it's a practice but the
more you do it not sound cliche that the
better you get at it but you start to
feel better too talk more about the
inner child because I've probably found
the most amount of growth and Clarity
with that connection like I had a really
cool EMDR our experience which I'm a big
big fan of it was sort of like a
conflict a dynamic and the information
was basically just that you know my
inner child has been afraid that I don't
talk to her trust her listen and so in
this sort of abandoning of maybe how I
really feel she would Retreat as if
because she didn't trust me and that it
was and it's not just like she's
symbiotically or she's not just some
higher power that's always in alignment
she's like an energy as well and that as
soon as I start to sort of validate her
then she's right there like it doesn't
take long it's not a hard trust
situation but and then once she's there
no matter what dynamic is in front of me
the information was that I feel calm and
okay because the number one relationship
I could ever have in my entire life is
that one so anything in front of me is
not a problem because I'm I'm now which
is what we're all seeking the best
relationship I'm in it like I'm
disgusting it and I'm in it and it was
just like this it's mind-blowing I know
right aliens yeah you know what's so
nice is that life gets actually a little
easier but it's not really that hard
when you do it because like you said it
really doesn't take long like people
think mental health or self-development
and opening the window and like doing
all this you know Dark Night of the soul
and like all these really deep spiritual
practices that we're having just to find
inner peace or whatever it is that we're
really searching for even just like
manifest things
um it doesn't take long once you kind of
start this process and I tell people the
one thing that we're not I always look
at mental health is a big umbrella and I
say okay there's Mental Health on this
side and then there's emotional health
on this side and emotional health and
we're taught mental health in terms of
how to push through you know motivation
like real logical things like that's not
real and fears like we understand these
logical aspects of mental health but the
emotional aspects we don't really learn
because most of us are taught to sweep
things under the rug it is what it is
there's nothing we can do about it we
have to push through you know we're
given that kind of tough love mentality
and we miss the emotional piece and you
can't go to you can do it you got this
without that emotional validation
soothing caring love nurturing you you
need that first because that's what
makes you human
you're not a robot you're not supposed
to skip over what you just innately feel
and like you said the minute you just
start kind of listening and giving her
what she needs and and you honor
yourself and you're like you know what
it actually doesn't work for me and I
don't want to do that right now and you
learn how to soothe yourself and work
through some of the codependencies
things just start getting easier and you
feel better because you are your own
best friend and when that relationship
gets really good first of all you start
picking way better partners because now
your measure what you're going off of is
higher your standard is higher because
you have this great relationship and you
feel good that the minute you can start
to sense something that doesn't feel
good you're okay with leaving it because
you don't need it in the way that you
did before so to kind of go back to that
first question that you were asking me
about narcissism and how to not attract
those relationships number one is
education but and understanding just
what narcissism is I mean I didn't know
any of that stuff but a big part is kind
of diving into your own self and
unfortunately sometimes you kind of have
to go to the Past a little bit and dip
your toe in it and just say okay well
what happened growing up what didn't I
get what was I supposed to get and what
was it supposed to look like and and
kind of unleashing those those wounds
you know abandonment and and betrayal
and violation and you know all of those
kind of emotional abuse wounds that we
sometimes carry with us that are
unhealed you know we go to therapy and
we talk it out which is great but have
you don't realize that they actually
still kind of show up in your day-to-day
life how would you coach someone through
being triggered because the trigger is
still the teacher the more you don't
judge the trigger and you allow it to be
there the more it stops showing up you
know what I mean like it's when you
ignore the trigger that it's gonna keep
going there because like you said it's a
trigger it's coming up for a reason so
my biggest thing is always to understand
and one of my triggers but what's the
story behind the trigger so it's not
your ex it was a story behind it so for
me my ex-husband left me for another
woman you know and now they're married
and they have children together so that
if that that was a trigger for years
with me and it wasn't her and it wasn't
the relationship it wasn't him leaving
me or anything like that it was what
that meant in my mind what did you think
or what did that mean to you I think the
story that in everyone's mind in my kind
of
someone is one is cruel to
you know like what did I do to deserve
this that's always like the biggest one
I want to talk about cheating somewhere
I read that men cheat to stay and women
cheat to leave why do people cheat them
I think
for different reasons I think I think
some people cheat because they don't
honor that they don't want to be with
this person you know that they maybe the
person isn't right for them
um and they don't want to admit that for
whatever reasons I think some people
cheat because they think the grass is
greener I think some people cheat
because they think that the next person
is going to be easier than this and they
don't usually and I kind of see it as
more with men than women when they start
dipping especially when you start
getting to like Affairs that's really I
don't want to deal with me
and so instead of not dealing with me
I'm just going to leave yeah and you
know the grass is never Greener but
there's an element of I don't want to
open this window and so I just I just
leave
some people get fired from the job I
think too yeah you know they kind of
just start to in the in in the back
office start to just really things
up you know they just start to make a
mess because they're not man or woman
enough to end something that they know
is not right so they get themselves
fired from the job
like this clip
whole episode
click at the bottom of your screen